so mr speaker i'm taking three further
steps
today first i'm introducing a new
grant scheme for businesses impacted by
tier two restrictions
even if they aren't legally closed
we will fund local authorities to
provide businesses in their area
with direct cash grants
it will be up to local authorities to
decide how best to distribute these
grants
giving them the necessary flexibility to
respond
to local economic circumstances but
i'm providing enough funding to give
every business premises
in the hospitality leisure and
accommodation sectors
a direct grant worth up to two thousand
one hundred pounds for every month tier
two restrictions
apply and that's equivalent to seventy
percent
of the value of the grants available for
closed businesses
in tier three and crucially
i am pleased to confirm these grants
will be retrospective
businesses in any area which has been
under enhanced restrictions
can back date their grants to august
i have been listening and engaging with
colleagues around the house
including but only my honourable friends
for hayward and middleton
heinbern peniston and stockbridge south
ribble
burnley keithley cheadle lee and
southpaw
and i'm pleased to confirm the back
dating of the new grants
means we are being more generous to
businesses and places
which have been under higher
restrictions for longer
let no one say mr speaker this
government is not committed to
supporting the people and businesses
in every region and nation of the united
kingdom
to protect jobs we are making the job
support scheme
more generous for employers if
businesses are legally required to close
as we've already outlined the government
will cover the full cost
of employers paying two-thirds of
people's salary
where they can't work for a week or more
for businesses who can open it is now
clear
the impact of restrictions on them
particularly in the hospitality sector
is more significant than they had hoped
so i'm making two changes to the short
time work scheme
to make it easier for those businesses
to keep staff on
rather than make them redundant
first under the original scheme
employees had to work for 33
of their normal hours now we will ask
them to work only 20
of those hours second the employer
contribution
for the hours not worked will not be 33
as originally planned or even 20
as it is in the october furlough scheme
it will reduce
to five percent and the scheme will
apply to eligible businesses
in all alert levels so businesses
that are not closed but face higher
restrictions
in places like liverpool lancashire
south yorkshire and greater manchester
as well as the devolved nations will be
able to access
greater support these changes
mean more employers can access the
scheme
and more jobs will be protected
we have made this one of the most
generous versions of a short time work
scheme
anywhere in the world it is better for
businesses
better for jobs and better for the
economy
third as we increase the contribution
we're making towards employees wages
i'm increasing our contribution to the
incomes of the self-employed as well
today we are doubling the next round of
the self-employed income support from 20
to 40 of people's incomes increasing the
maximum grant
to 3750 pounds
so far through this crisis we have now
provided over 13 billion pounds of
support
to self-employed workers sole traders
small businesses and self-employed
people are the dynamic
entrepreneurial heart of our economy and
this government
is on their side in conclusion mr
speaker
a wage subsidy for closed businesses
a wage subsidy for open businesses
cash grants of over two thousand pounds
a month for tier two businesses
and up to three thousand pounds a month
for closed businesses
support for local authorities support
for the self-employed support for
people's jobs
and incomes all on top of over 200
billion pounds of support
since march this is our plan
a plan for jobs for businesses for the
regions
for the economy for the country a plan
to support the british people
and i commend this statement to the
house